[Music]
all right guys what's up welcome back to
prepare like a pro so in this segment
we're going to be looking at some games
in which I played the black pieces and
thanks to my Superior preparation and
understanding of the opening position I
was able to get fighting position with
black and ultimately win these games so
let's start off with this one right here
in Black was round one of a five rounder
tournament some years ago so all these
games are going to take place in the
English opening which starts with one
C4 I played E5 again many moves here for
black but my preparation was centered
around the following system Knight C3
Bishop B4 now I have no idea what this
is called but when I looked it up before
the class apparently they call this the
kramnick Shar off Counterattack which
makes no sense to me considering it's
not particularly aggressive and you
would think an opening named after or
variation after Shar of would would lead
to fire on the board but this is more of
a positional approach so I guess the
crck part makes sense but the sheriff
part is a bit weird apparently that's
what it's called so what's the point of
this move typically black plays Knight
F6 and they want to play for D5 grab
space in the center white usually goes
something like
G3 and black drops back Knight B6 Knight
C6 Bishop B7 castle with a long game
ahead so by playing Bishop B4 I'm
immediately posing a question to White
is he ready to play the structure
arising after Bishop take C3 which would
double his
structure so how does he feel about
taking with the B Pawn or the D Pawn is
he ready to play that position it has
some advantages but it also has some
drawbacks his pawns could be Targets
later it also weakens the Integrity of
his Pawn structure so why has to decide
does he want to allow me to play Bishop
takes C3 or does he want to maybe
prevent that so there are few ways white
can do
that most aggressive one in the main
line is with Knight D5 so white
immediately jumps with the Knight to the
center hitting the bishop
and black can drop back to either
C5 or E7 both moves are very solid and
white usually follows up with Knight F3
and tries to get D4 in and the position
is about
equal in the game though my opponent
decided he was comfortable playing with
the structure and you decided to play
G3 so I didn't rush to take on C3 yet
played Knight F6 first because I figured
White's already kind of shown his hand
that he's not going to prevent me from
taking on C three so I have that move
whenever I want pretty much so I
developed my knight out white played
Bishop
G2 I castled and he went
E3 so now he has a specific idea in mind
that's why I took on C3 so the question
is what's White's idea if I don't play
Bishop takes C3 what can he play on the
next move which makes my idea of Bishop
B4 in the opening look rather silly what
up Daniel Su combo if you guys heard
that question if you feel free to chime
in and answer I'm monitoring the chat
we've got no in-person audience so all
the attention is on you
guys so why does it make sense for black
to take on C3 here immediately we
already knew that that was the plan to
begin with but there's a specific reason
we got to do it
now what's the move White's trying to
play with
E3 what's up liberated
toaster
be interested to hear that
story yeah very good Royal Fork Knight
G2 white wants to develop his Knight to
to E2 so this is a multi-purpose Move It
prepares D4 eventually but it also sets
up Knight G2 and then he reinforces the
Knight on C3 so let's say I made a
random move like Rook E8 which seems
decent enough white goes Knight E2 and
all of a sudden taking on C3 doesn't
make any sense anymore I would just give
up the bishop for the Knight but I don't
don't spoil this Pawn structure so that
would be a bad
decision that's why here we got to take
on C3 immediately which is what I did
and he took with the D Pawn which was
rather surprising I expected him to take
with the B
Pawn capturing towards the center and
again either playing for D4 or maybe D3
E4 and potentially something like Knight
E2 and F4 later
on steady took on
C3 now it's black to play how can we
sort of punish this decision it's not a
tactic it's just a positional
move so what move can we play which
makes D take C3 look rather silly now
remember think about White's Bishop on
C1 it's hemmed in right now can't go
anywhere so think about what white might
do to try to open up that bishop and if
there's a way we can stop
that yep good job Samu that was the
point of White's move to play Knight
E2 so what should black play now
all right toaster thinks we should play
E4 do we all agree with
that okay we've got another suggestion
C6
interesting so toaster why do you like
E4 what are you accomplishing with this
move and Daniel in response to C6 think
what white might play so with C6 I
assume you want to play D5 so now think
how white might try to prevent that and
then judge is that better for us or
better for for the
opponent
all right D6 another suggestion all
right Mr M likes E4 as
well okay some good some good discussion
going on here all right so let's look at
C6 first because this move is quite
logical we we want to play D5 now d
suggests white can play Queen D6
here very interesting suggestion so he's
blocking the D Pawn from advancing and
if black can get rid of this queen his
piece is going to be all stuck if he can
get the D Pawn moving then the bishop on
C8 is stuck and the position is just
very passive I don't think this would be
the best way to go about it for white
though because black can play Rook E8
here which supports the pawn and on the
next move we're going to kick that Queen
out with Rook E6 and get D5 in but I
think the problem at C6 is white plays
E4 he takes that away and now now we
can't play
D5 and he also opens up that Bishop on
C1 remember I said White's Bishop on C1
is blocked in by his pawns so what move
would he want to play that would get his
Bishop out and that move is E4 so after
he gets E4 in his Bishop's looking very
happy all of a sudden it could come to
E3 could come to
G5 so that's why we need to play E4 here
so we stop white from playing
E4 we potentially get the D3 Square for
our pieces and we free up the E5 Square
for our pieces so imagine we could get
Knight C6 Knight E5 we'd have this huge
outpost on D3 to work with and we also
shut down this bishop on G2 it's a very
simple but multi-purpose move which
takes away White's ideas and opens up
some ideas for our for our own
pieces all right
guys interesting convo about the
toaster all right so white decided that
he didn't want to defend passively here
if he continued with something like
Knight E2 let's say he just wants the
castle once Black's Knight comes to E5
this is very unpleasant for white so the
C4 Pawn is attacked B3 and D6 and all of
a sudden White's in big trouble here
that Bishop's coming out to
G4 taking advantage of that weak F3
square and it's not really easy to
suggest anything for white like he's
literally helpless here against the idea
of Bishop G4 setting up Knight F3 or
Bishop F3
in essence he's just waiting to be
beaten here he has no prospects in this
position this bishop is so bad which
this move e E4 really emphasizes this
bishop has like nowhere to go it's just
completely shut in could try coming out
to A3 but we could always play a move
like C5 again just killing that bishop
and its
scope so white wanted to avoid something
like that that's why he decided to last
shot with
G4 so his point is to play G5 kick our
Knight
away and then take on E 4 now we don't
want to play a move like H6 because that
could potentially play into White's
hands he would follow up with H4 G5 and
if the H file opens up all of a sudden
it's white who's playing for the win he
going to get a nasty attack so we don't
want to create any weaknesses of our own
on the king side so how should black
react to
G4 it's a tricky move to deal
with because G5 is a
threat but we need to assess what
happens after G5 so what should we play
first all right ugly base player D5
makes sense right we're striking in the
center in response to a flank
attack D5 Pawn is protected for the
moment but again after G5 we got to ask
ourselves what's going on here that
Knight's again under attack and after it
moves the D5 Pawn drops right white do
two attackers we only have one Defender
after this Knight moves so we can't lash
out with
D5 okay Queen E7 also a very good
suggestion it's not the move I play but
I think it's a reasonable
move so we reinforce the E4 pawn and I
guess we're prepared to me G5 with
Knight E8 perfectly good move what else
can we play here
think about a move which helps us
develop our pieces on the queen side
like in particular the bishop so D5
doesn't work what else can we
play something a bit more
calm
yep very good
D6 so I realize that after he goes G5
Knight D7 he can grab this Pawn on e4
but I still like my position after I
take on G5 I do lose this important E4
Pawn but now his King side is extremely
weak he has no attack on the king side
he's lost this G Pawn his King is going
to be in some in some big trouble now he
can never
castle and his pieces just look very
underdeveloped still everything is
pretty much on the back Rank and he just
got this bishop on
e4 so I thought okay even if we allow G5
he grabs our Central Pawn we take on G5
it's still very difficult for white to
play so he played Knight F3 developing
his pieces and with the tempo I drop
back to
E7 so I'm hitting the
bishop he went back to
C2 I got my knight
out he played Knight
D4 now what do you think we should play
here should we trade this Knight or
not move like Knight takes D4 who does
that
benefit what was your reasoning
toaster okay all of you like 95 I assume
you mean Knight
C5 yep very good reasoning we don't want
to fix we don't want to repair White
pawns Knight takes D4 would be a big
mistake C takes D4 we fix this Pawn
structure and we give this bishop life
again it could come to C3 potentially
look at our King side Knight takes D4
would be a terrible positional
mistake you guys all spotted that and
suggest Knight C5 very good so we avoid
that exchange and we attack C4 Pawn the
C4
Pawn oh sorry uh Knight D5 getting my
Knights mixed
up so now if he takes on
C6 I can just take with the B Pawn C5
could open up that Bishop which would
look at White's King
side so he played Bishop
E4 weird move but it's already getting
unpleasant for for white if he goes
something like B3
then all of a sudden Bishop G4 that
Bishop Springs to life and he's going to
have problems along this diagonal can't
play F3 because the Knight takes D4 now
he takes we can take that pawn on
F3 and basically if he allows Bishop G4
it's more or less game over he's just
losing material here he moves that Queen
we take on D4 and Knight F3 comes with
check for king the king and queen so
Bishop E4 it's a weird move but his idea
is to meet Bishop G4 with
F3 and now the F3 Pawn is
defended so what move can we play here
which would take away the f F3 idea for
white and again set up Bishop
G4 how can we prevent white from playing
F3
here okay Queen H4 is a suggestion F5 is
a suggestion Drew does F5 prevent F3
though if you play a move like F5 he'll
throw in this check you'll get a little
Tempo King h8 and maybe he'll play
something like I don't know Queen E2 and
he'll try to get Bishop D2 and Castle
his King to the queen side or it'll be
reasonably
safe so F5 right idea in the sense that
we want to play aggressively and with
the initiative but Bishop D5
check followed by Queen E2 probably is
okay for white so we want to play a
little bit
more carefully again we would love to
play Bishop G4 but F3 stops that so how
can we take away F3 from White and again
set up Bishop
G4 okay lot of you guys like Queen
H4 seu does Queen F6 take away F3 though
remember we want to set up Bishop
G4 I can go F3 here
maybe
it seems all of you are pretty much in
agreement yep Queen H4 so we attack that
bishop and we P that F2 pawn and now
Bishop G4 is coming and white can't
really stop
that first of all he's got to deal with
the threat to that E4 Bishop so he
played Queen
C2 at least he's getting out of the
tempo on
G4 I play Bishop G4 that F3 square is
super soft now he played H3 attacking my
Bishop what should we play here now we
need to transform the position here in a
way that's favorable to us to do that we
may have to make a move we didn't want
to make earlier so how can we take
advantage of this F3 Square think on
think on positional
terms so we know this bishop on C1 is
terrible right so if we can isolate
white with that Bishop
from a positional standpoint we're doing
very
well uh one sec let me just answer this
so yeah you do have Queen H4 but
something like Queen uh King E2 I think
is okay for white can't really get to
his King now maybe Queen E1 next to
offer a trade slowly he might get his
King over to that Queen side all right
so let's go back
here so how do we transform this
position in a way which we can isolate
white with that terrible Bishop on
C1 okay if you go F5 think about White's
response to that remember this Bishop's
under attack and it is protected by The
Rook on H1 is protected by the bishop on
e4 so if you go F5 he can just take that
and then he just lose a
piece
okay so let's see Knight takes D4 it's
the most obvious move in the position we
make a
trade uh White takes back with the c
Pawn obviously if he opens up the E file
with e takes
D4 that's going to end in disaster a
rook will end up on E8 eventually so
he's got to take with the c Pawn
question is what should we play after
that do we move the bishop to F3 or the
Knight to
F3
okay one of you guys like Knight
F3 so let look at that Knight takes she
takes Knight F3 giving a check now if he
takes
again he's got this terrible Bishop on
C1 and we've got this dominant Bishop on
F3 and this king is stuck it can't run
anywhere so we're probably going to win
here after Knight F3 what if he goes
King
F1 seems like this move shouldn't be
possible but it is if we take on H3 he
goes up to E2 so he sacked a pawn but
we've walked into this pin on the H file
and our Knight on F3 is hanging all of a
sudden it's a mess
so Knight F3 is not quite
working so then we start looking at
Bishop F3 so why is Bishop F3
better what's the positional point of
this
move right toaster but like the line I
just showed King F1 the tactics aren't
working out for
us
so what's special about Bishop
F3 what do we get here by forcing the
trade of the
Bishops very good
Daniel it's exactly
right we isolate why with that bad
Bishop on C1 and we have a very strong
active Knight cemented on F3
uh ugly Bas player are you talking
about are you talking about Knight takes
D4
here if this is what you mean this
doesn't work because he takes D4 Bishop
G4 like I'll just move the king
somewhere that Rook on H1 is protected
right then we just
lose can't take on
one so Bishop F3 is very important so
white
took King F1 now
again we're better here and we have the
positional Advantage but if we give
white time he's going to consolidate
potentially freeze pieces so if it's
White's move
here what is he trying to
get think about it from that perspective
if it was white to play what does he
want to
do is a very nasty threat
here for not careful we could actually
lose in one
move Believe It or
Not K Nicholson why do you like F5
I need a reasoning for the next move
because there's a very important Point
behind
it all right very good consideration
Arjun E4 is something we have to look
out for it doesn't quite work for me yet
though because Knight takes D4 but it's
important that we still consider it so
that's good he has a more devious threat
here so let me flip the board if it's
white smooth what are you playing here
this would be essentially white to play
and win the
game Queen E4 the queen is covering
it wait guys I actually made a mistake
it's not it's not to win but it's still
a annoying move to face I just realized
black has a defense
there okay so most of you guys have
suggested some V variation of that move
so Queen F5 yeah so let's just make a
random move for black to demonstrate
Queen F5 for some reason I completely
forgot that I can play Knight G5 here I
thought the Knight was trapped but
Knight G5 is possible but again we would
have to move that Knight to a very
awkward
square and white can consolidate now he
can expand further with F4 and all of a
sudden we've lost lost all those
advantages we've had Knight has to go
back this King will come to safety this
bishop might come out to D2 then White's
doing all right so it's it's this
tactical and positional threat in a way
for some reason I thought this was
trapping the Knight but we do have
Knight G5 but it's not a move we want to
make right we don't we don't want to
move that knight from
F3 I just wedged into White's position
doing a great job so Queen F5 is
basically the threat to kick our Knight
away
So based on that what should we
play yeah Rook A8 is a good idea but
again we have to deal with Queen F5
otherwise Rook a would be perfect now
that we know that he wants queen F5 we
got to take that away
first yep very good so
F5 so we take away Queen F5 and we take
control of the E4 Square so we pretty
much shut down E4
forever and just look at the position
why does white is essentially running
out of moves I mean he's helpless to
Black just slowly bringing his pieces
into the attack with like Rook E8 maybe
The Rook comes up swings over maybe I
decide to break things open with F4
later he essentially has no moves his
King is
stuck and his pieces are not
developed
uh G6 to stop it uh that does stop it
but I think a move like F5 would be more
useful than G6 because F5 also takes
away the E4 square if you play G6 you
also take away this rank which you could
use your Rook for you know when you get
your Rook into the attack like a rook
lift so G6 is less
flexible so
F5 my opponent played C5 trying to open
things up trying to get some counter
playay maybe Queen B3 check hitting the
king and the pawn
so what do you think should we take that
pawn or can we do
to keep a clamp on White's
position yep very good D5 again just a
simple move taking away White's ideas
further clamping down on that E4 square
and again look at all his pawns they're
on the dark Square his Bishops on the
dark Square it's not helping the case
for his
Bishop so white decided he'll go Queen
B3 anyways hitting D5 and hitting B7
it's a double
attack but we have a very nice way to
end the game now
here we just play one move and white is
defenseless against all of our
threats
so look at White's pieces Rook on H1 is
unprotected King on F1 could be a Target
how can we put that all
together it's a move which attacks and
defends at the same
time that D5 Pawn is more important than
this B7 Pawn we don't care about this
Pawn but if he takes on D5 it comes with
a check and hits our Knight so how do we
defend this Pawn while also creating a
bunch of threats in the position
all right Queen
E4 okay let's
see that looks logical we defend that
pawn and we create threats in the
position all right first question what
if I try to run with King
E2 so maybe next Mo I want to play Rook
D1 get my Rook out of that corner into a
more secure
Square
yep very good knight takes
D4 nice discover check you can't take is
a Pawn's pin and we'll pick up the queen
on the next move and this Rook is
hanging so everything's hanging for
white so you can't do
that so let's
say let's come up with a move here for
white what if I play Queen
C3 so what was the threat all the along
he
all right so there many good there many
good toaster you don't want to know just
uh some guys who are playing outside and
getting into dispute uh probably about
they're probably also mad about the
oppression of toasters so Queen C3 um
Knight D2 is possible hitting the king
attacking that Rook on
H1 and he goes King G1
so okay many moves win here guys uh
Knight takes D4 is almost certainly good
as well we do have to deal with Rook G1
though can't go back to F3 because of
Queen G7 but we do have Knight
E6 but I want you guys to find the most
forceful way to finish your off so
Knight D2 good start so we're attacking
that Rook so if he decides to take the
Knight and give up the exchange game is
pretty much over anyways we're up
material so what do we do after King G1
it's an idea we talked about earlier
R streaming IM am did that with me once
in 2013 in a in a Blitz game in a rated
Blitz game and he got away with it he
just uh dug up some old
trauma
yeah very good Rook
F6 that's also why this F5 move was more
flexible than than G6 right if we played
G6 we wouldn't have that square but now
we do have Rook F6 coming and Rook G6 is
going to create all sorts of problems
for white he has no defense against this
Rook enters into the game with decisive
effect where threatening made entally
with Rook
G6 and queen G2 and he can't stop it I
mean even he plays move like Rook h to
it doesn't matter everything's
covered so yeah my opponent just
resigned after Queen E4 cuz he's pretty
much out of moves and I have so many
threats I don't I don't even have to
rush like for example after that Queen
C3 move what if I just play Rook A8
right he literally has no moves I can
take my time with the Rook lift or I
could even set up F4 pretty much
anything wins so he decided to throw in
the towel there after King
E2 oh sorry after Queen E4 all right
good job guys let's go to the next one
same opening slightly different
variation though so got this bishop E4
system
again uh my opponent played Queen
C2 so he is reinforcing that Knight on
C3 if I take on C3 now he's prepared to
take with the queen keeping his Pawn
structor intact so we don't want to do
that so now I just develop Knight
F6 well he never really had a good
chance to do that base player I would
always after F5 he could never play E4 I
would just take right F takes E4 that
opens up the f file as
well so Knight
F3 attacking my Pawn I go Knight
C6 E3 D6 so I'm just developing so is
he now he goes Knight
D5 should we take this Knight or should
we look for a square to move our Bishop
to Knight takes D5 is what we need to
consider first right it's an exchange we
need to evaluate if it's good for us or
not so what happens after Knight takes
D5 white takes back
cd5 what's going on
there
yeah very
good so if we grab that KN on D5 cd5 run
into this nasty
check which attacks our Bishop on B4 as
well this is something we we always have
to be vigilant about when our Bishop's
on B4 and the king is still on E8 Queen
A4 is always an idea on these
positions so we can take on D5 uh you
guys are suggesting Bishop C5 and A5 all
moves are good here I played Bishop A5
doesn't really matter as long as you
don't take on D5 you're doing
well he played
A3 so he's trying to play B4 expand on
the queen side push my Bishop back maybe
get his Bishop out to
B2 I decided to take now because Queen
A4 can be met
by what happens if he goes Queen A4
here
what can I play now that my Bishop's on
A5 yeah very good
C6 Queen protects that Bishop more than
happy to make this
trade all of a sudden we have very good
control of the center we've got three
pawns coming in the center White's pawns
are still relatively passive o sorry we
went a little bit ahead there all right
D6 Knight D5 B F5 A3 so I took took
Knight E7 so I'm attacking the D5
Pawn B4 Bishop C6 he defends
it already we can see that White's
position is not looking very comfortable
all of a sudden that pawn on D5 is kind
of a sore sight I mean the bishop is
also passively defending it on
D5 black could now have potential on the
king side with a move like F5 so let's
see what happened Castle
cast so all right so what should white
play what should black play here
now so think about how we can start
getting an initiative around the king
side so move like F5 for instance what I
mentioned it's a bit premature still
because of Knight G5 we don't want that
Knight to come into E6
potentially so forget about ideas like
F5 we want to prioritize our pieces
first so how can we start creating some
ideas on the king side here
yeah very good Bishop
G4 so we develop our Bishop and we are
in fact pretty much threatening to take
on F3 so let's demonstrate what would
happen let's make a random move for
white so let's say white allows this we
spoil the structure and we open up the
king now how do we get our pieces closer
to the king side what move do we play
here yeah DM that would be fine
but I didn't want you guys to think in
that direction it's not really about F5
at this moment I wanted you to find
Bishop G4 making a move with your
piece yeah very good knight
G6 now that Knight could hop into H4 and
once it comes to H4 that F3 Pawn is
going to be super weak Knight H4 Queen
F6 it's going to be very hard for white
to defend that pawn Knight A5 right idea
but doesn't quite work because Knight's
not protected he can just take on F5
that's why we go from
G6 so obviously white doesn't want to
allow that he played Knight
G5 is he threatening something or is
that just a random
move let's see who's actually paying
attention
okay it seems like you guys saw the
threat yeah he's obviously threatening M
on H7 we don't want to allow that all
right so many suggestions here F5 again
we don't want to play this move
especially with the Knight on G5 because
it gives up that E6 square that Knight
comes into E6 the nasty
Fork
so if all else fails we'll have to use
one of our
pawns to block the mate would have to be
G6 but if we can do it with the piece
that would be even better right we want
to get our pieces into the game so is
there a way which we can block that mate
with one of our
pieces while also bringing it into the
game again we're trying to get that
kingside initiative going because he
doesn't have many Defenders around his
King okay Bishop f51 suggestion
Bishop
F5 I didn't like Bishop D3 because it
kind of forces a trade of pieces I don't
want to trade this bishop off this
bishop is pretty bad on
C4 what's another way which we can block
that attack on H7 all right Knight G6
Knight F5
okay
um so Knight G6 is the move I'm looking
for Knight F5 also interesting we attack
the Knight just seems less stable to
because it's relying on this bishop to
protect it and a move like A3 comes it's
going to it's going to be really
annoying can't protect that Knight
anymore so like let's say he would go
back or I don't know maybe not Knight
E4 oh what if he tries this Knight F3
back so now if we take he'll take on F5
what about
that that may be why I didn't play
Knight
F5 because it gives him this silly
resource of just going back so if the
knight's on G6 he can't do that right
because then we take on F3 in general
just Knight G6 here is more secure it's
protected and it's not blocking the path
of the
bishop all right he played Knight
E4 so what do you guys think I should
play here now we've gotten our Knight
activated we could hop to
H4 but already we can start thinking
about the F5 idea which we want to which
we want to play now so do we rush with
F5 or should we play something else
first what happens after
F5 why might you want to wait with this
move
first how does it affect our other
pieces
so if we play F5
here what happens to one of our
pieces
y very good the light scrip Bishop would
get cramped on G4 and uh he fights with
knights also points at a very
interesting resource white has F3 or
maybe even
H3 maybe H3 is even a bit better than F3
very good so if we take he takes back
he's happy to make that trade get that
monster Bishop off the board and now
he's going to take on e4 next we can
protect that and if we go Bishop
H5 what does he play
here yeah he would play Knight G3
exactly and our Bishop's trapped so
Bishop H3 is a good suggestion
here
um G takes I guess we take take I mean
this still looks good for black but it
feels like white has made some progress
he's got that light Square Bishop off
the
board that would make his defensive task
easier I think we want to keep that
Bishop but this would also be better for
black but I think there's a move that's
stronger because it doesn't get involved
in all this
Preparatory move for
F5 now we don't have to waste time with
H6 now because the G5 sore is covered by
the queen so let's not think about H6
anymore we want to play F5 but we need
to make sure this bishop is on a
comfortable Square so what should we
play
first yeah it could be he fights with
knights I wasn't
sure maybe F3 is a better try because of
that I think both lines though Black's
better but white is
still very much in the game his defense
becomes easier compared to what happened
in the
game okay yeah very good Bishop D7 so I
just dropped my Bishop back to more safe
square and now I'm ready to play
F5 and we don't have to get worried
about the bishop getting harassed on G4
so he played Bishop
E2 played F5 finally Knight
C3 charged forward with
F4 and he played Knight
E4 so what should we play here can we
strike right
now so his idea is to
play Knight H4 which looks like very
natural Mo we bring F3 he wants to play
F3
himself take away that
resource
so that's White's idea so if we know
white wants to play F3 we have to start
thinking what if we play F3 first we are
sacking some material but maybe there
are Tactical justifications for
it so is F3 something which we should
play for example F3 Bishop takes
F3 do we just give up a pawn or do we
have an idea
here yes thank you he fights with
knights okay very good so we're looking
at Rook takes
F3 so let's see Rook takes F3 what's the
point of this move gf3 we just gave up a
pawn and an exchange what are we getting
in
return uh Bishop H3 he fights with
knights again remember opponent's not
obliged to capture he doesn't have to
take on H3 if he doesn't take on H3 he
don't really have a point
right so let's look at the more forcing
move first Rook F3 gf3 how do we
evaluate this
position what do we have going for us
now that we've gotten this bishop off
the board and open up the G
file
so not really looking for a move just an
explanation a quick explanation of what
black has going for him after he sacked
that exchange and pawn what was the
point of all that why did we give up
that
material all the moves you guys are
suggesting are good and correct you
could just articulate the reasoning
behind
it so besides stopping white for playing
F3 himself what do we accomplish by
getting rid of that light squ Bishop
okay very good Daniel the king is also
weakend yeah very good ugly base player
that's pretty much what I was looking
for we weakened the king and more
importantly we exploit the white squares
now the light squares White's light
Square Bishop is off the board and all
of a sudden he's going to have a very
tough time defending those squares
around the king so many moves here are
good I played Knight G Knight
H4
yeah uh good way of explaining it seal
blue basically all the pieces that are
playing are on the king side are going
to be on the king side and their Black's
pieces like White's pieces on A1 C1
don't really matter that Bishop on C1
like we saw in the first game again it's
such a terrible
piece so Knight
G3 took the pawn I mean he he has a
tough time defending the F3 Pawn so he
decided to sacrifice it King G2 so he's
hoping I go back Knight H4 and then he
runs back to H1 maybe he can try to hold
this
but we're not going to allow that so
what's the move which which we would
like to play here which sets up mating
threats we want to keep that Knight on
F3 so what move in com what piece in
combination with that Knight would
create mating
threats
we need something else along with that
Knight Queen very good yes we want to
get our Queen into the
attack the boort glitching or a
Ben guys I don't think the board is
glitching Maybe refresh if you think it
is okay great so yeah we'd love to get
our Queen into the game
right move like Queen H4 comes to mind
we're attacking H2 but the Knight on F3
is
hanging so what you should do here is
here you have to consider Queen H4 but
don't jump off the line too
quickly so Queen H4 we're threatening to
take on H2 but we have to calculate King
takes F3 so what's going on
there if we can make Queen H4 work the
game is essentially over on the spot we
don't want to let white
Escape okay sweet toaster I guess the
board's been
liberated yeah very good so if Queen H4
King
F3 we have Bishop G4
check hitting that King so if he goes
back you guys have correctly
realized Queen
H3 no matter where the king moves Bishop
F3 and all of a sudden it's made on G2
he can't stop that those weak light
sores which we were talking about can
finally see the
purpose out of curiosity what if he runs
up to E4 now we do have Bishop D1 made
uh sorry not M winning the queen but
there there's actually a
forced is there a forced Checkmate here
I think there
is oh well actually okay so I was going
to say Bishop F5 is a force check made
but technically white can run back here
and give up the queen anyways that's
actually his best move so rather I'll
ask you after Bishop F5 what if he takes
here what's the force mate
here
yeah Bishop B2 also good I mean maybe he
has F4
there but Bishop F5 it's a double check
so it kind of forces him to move the
king so let's say he takes an F5 he has
no shame how do we M him
here Rook f it obviously very natural
move King
E6 finish it
off let's try to visualize it from this
position so Rook f8 King E6 how do we
catch that
King yeah very good
DM it's probably the simplest because
it's all checks it's all
forcing we normally have to calculate
too much there very good so Rook f8 King
E6 Queen F6 check again driving that
King to
D7 the king is so offside Queen d8 again
again another check come back but now we
swap places with the rook and rookie F6
is
made so once we realize Queen H4 King
takes F3 doesn't work intuitively we
should feel that this is the right move
we bring our Queen into the attack we
set up a threat on H2 and we're
preparing to play Rook f8 to cement that
KN on
F3 white played Knight
F5 Queen G4
Knight
G3 rook
f8 and black uh and white resigned here
because what's my
threat what am I threatening with Rook
f8 now now that the Knight is
protected was there a quick remid
probably guys but uh Queen D Rook F6 the
M eyesu they we're rolling with
that
yeah very good Queen H3 and queen H2 is
Unstoppable so it's white resign it's
kind of funny again in this game this
bishop on C1 is just dead the dark
Square Bishop had never had any effect
in the game whatsoever both of his
Bishops didn't
actually so yeah this line with C4 E5
Knight C3 Bishop
B4 I've played it with great success
I've won a bunch of games even against
strong strong FM level players beaten
some items as well and it's a good
choice I think even for for lower levels
because there's not much Theory I mean
people are starting to analyze it now
it's just a bit annoying but in general
you're going to get very straightforward
positions and it's easy for white to go
wrong like if he allows this structure
with Bishop takes C3 he has to really
know what he's doing to not get worse as
we saw in this
game playing the structure with DT C3 is
super risky especially when you've
played E3 that allows E4 but even with
the pawn and E2 white really needs to
know what he's doing so I think C4 E5
Knights to Bishop pretty decent line for
black and a lot of your opponents are
not going to be super well prepared here
I think every game I've played this all
my opponents even though they they know
it's coming They Don't Really pose many
problems in the opening so it could be
one of those lines which is relatively
unexplored and can also help you to
surprise your opponents check it out I
think it would be a a good resource to
have all right so I don't think I have
time to get into the next game it's
going to take way too long so we're
probably going to end things here now
unless we have some questions
yeah that's true they do play
G3 this is certainly more topical these
days I agree I don't know if it's
necessarily to avoid the bishop B4 line
but that could be one reason of course
this has its own
issues
C6 is a popular response you know black
drives to fight for D5 immediately so
yeah both moves have their drw you know
advantages and drawbacks it's it's a
matter of preference
really that's why some players play
Knight C3 because they don't want to
allow the C6
line what's for lunch probably a piece
of
toast is there a difference after G3
Knight F6 six Knight C3 yeah so this
move order is considered imprecise if
you mix G3 with Knight C3 like this it's
considered imprecise because the bishop
B4 usually white wants to meet this move
with Knight D5 but the bishop should be
on G2 for that
already something like this is
considered to be very fine for
black white players have been trying E4
here to get a reversed russal Lio so
what is that so this
position sorry let's flip it
so this line against the russal Lio is
essentially uh let me play Bishop
C let make some moves just to
demonstrate so something like this this
is essentially what White's trying to
get but he's up a Tempo now because he's
white Carlson played this a few times
with some success he's basically trying
to play a line with black but with white
so he's up a Tempo but again it's
considered to be very good for black I
mean black has no issues really from a
theoretical standpoint usually
takes uh I think white takes with a d
Pawn Castle they play something weird
like this with
F3 black plays C6 goes for D5 and it's
it's pretty
balanced white often times ends up worse
so that's why after G3 it's almost
certainly recommended to play Bish
Bishop G2 or if you go Knight C3 Knight
F6 if you want to play the G3 systems
play Knight F3
first because once the Knight comes to
C6 this is a bit different
now Bishop B4 Knight D5 now if you take
there's a Tempo on the C6 Knight right
and the E5 Pawn could be
hanging uh yeah I don't think taking on
e4 is good uh let me just go there
assume you mean
here I think think I don't know exactly
why but based on what I'm looking at now
I'm assuming it's Queen G4 the double
attack on G7 and
E4 and you probably don't want to allow
Queen G7 right that would mess up your
kingside structure and weaken all the
dark
squares did ding really play this in the
world championship with Knight C3 and E4
I don't I don't really
remember
if he's talking about this L then yeah
it is pretty
armless um there's also this which is a
bit different but very popular as well
E4
um don't know if I describe it as
harmless but of course black should be
fine but there are a bunch of ideas here
many systems for both sides you just got
to pick one and make sure you study it
well yeah Queen D5 was also possible but
I think you'd rather pick up the G7 Pawn
there than the E5
one okay if he imitated Carlson's line
then it's probably this one I don't
remember that at all though but again
this is not good I'm pretty sure
computers will show this is better for
black already so yeah don't try this at
home if you're if you're going to play
this as white you're going to play the
English as white definitely don't play
this
it's very difficult position to
play he's still pretty strong didn't he
play in the grand Swiss he maintains a
2650 rating or so say that's pretty
good
well G G3 in general it's easier to to
get winning chances in in openings which
aren't as explored in which the opponent
might not be as well prepared for I mean
obviously guy like NEPA would have
checked that pretty extensively even
even even in the London and col for the
world championship match but that's
probably not what he's expecting right
before the game he probably would be
expecting D4 C4 stuff or just Mainline
English that already throws the opponent
off you know he can't probably remember
his
preparation he's got to play some moves
on his own in the opening it's easy to
make some inaccuracies which tend to
snowball because I mean you could play
Just Mainline every game D4 C4 and just
bang your head against the wall but
everyone's so well prepared these days
especially at the top sometimes it's
good to switch it up even in a world
championship
match all right I guess we're done then
thanks guys great chat tonight you did a
great job with the positions and some
engaging conversation in the comments as
well so going to be signing off now have
a good night everyone see you next
[Music]
time